do you think this particular form of
philanthropy its have you seen it be
compatible compatible with with other
forms maybe not as you know large coming
from you know large private enterprise
is there a lot of partnership there do
you even think of it as that's right no
I don't I don't think of it as a
philanthropy but I think that you know a
lot of philanthropists and a lot of
people who come from that side who are
driven by impact are more and more
attracted to this form of achieving the
social impact I look at it and we've
discussed it a bit I you know during
lunch is that you can be a purist and
you say i want my dollar to alleviate
you know poverty directly and you can
say look i want 90 cents of impact per
dollar of my investments and i'm willing
to give ten dollars to this course oh
you can say let's find an opportunity
where I will get good financial return
and I will achieve 20 30 cents per
dollar of impact but because I receive
the returned I'm willing to put 10,000
of those dollars you calculate your
impact would be much higher because i
think this notion of financial
sustainability liberates huge amounts of
capital in addition to liberating also
the inter preneur oriole dr of finding
the solutions where you accountable for
the products if you give a product as a
grant say this is the same solar lamp
you don't care how good it is if you
sell it even for a fraction of the cost
that you will sell it in the West you
are accountable to your customers they
have to buy it they have to like it they
have to come they can come back to you
and say this is really it doesn't work
you make it better make it cheaper make
it last
and what is important you treat people
as consumers you treat investees as
partners not as the nation thing so it's
much more empowering but I think I think
also it might be helpful to look at it
from the perspective of philanthropists
that that get into what we could now
call the impact investment space and
I'll give you the example of a of a
family office in California that I used
to work with quite a lot when I was a
tourist capital and they invested in a
number of our funds 80 people full time
working on this family's wealth very
significant family office and the
particular family member that did
ultimately invest in a Latin America
funded in Africa fond had a very nuanced
view of what she was doing and why she
was doing it so she had her philanthropy
books and she was very clear about what
that might achieve too many of Julia's
points what was interesting about the
way that she approached this impact
investing box and this is private equity
fund going into small and medium-sized
enterprises was there is an economic
development story happening in Africa
where we are and Latin America where we
are empowering small businesses with
capital that they can't get from formal
financial institutions I am
participating in both an economic
development story in a wealth building
story because these companies would
really grow and take on more workers and
I am also doing good in that broader
amorphous sense so she perceived it in
its own right as something related to
but but but different to philanthropy